hello and welcome to this video playing
Wagner be I've Wexler by either no but
it's a banker h3y do you want to play h3
in this position nobody knows okay start
with this h3 is basically a temple down
on the normal line I mean h3 is semi
useful 94 should work in this position
why doesn't it takes takes takes
assume the position it works why doesn't
it work here
very irritating come out don't quite
remember they are then this is okay for
her very strange why did that work okay
okay i can still play this play this
position fairly standard bank oh yeah
maybe not so standard it's a bit
annoying that he got this in so
I'm getting this to the six just to
prevent 95 ok let's go he ran from 94
might be five I can take I mean what
yeah ok ok how to do it what's the
easiest win from they just take
everything off and wide ok but I wonder
what would happen here in the opening
usually you cannot play this 22 and last
night d phi is not 94 this is my thing
I'm here you know there is this line
efore 385 Bishop d3 which does not work
and now because of that I'm 95 is the
trick and I had a complete complete
brain slip the housing why doesn't it
work a tempo up and I was just thinking
about night before which does not
represent a yeah and now that's a double
attack essentially so like winds here so
I could have taken on d5 I was just
somehow just thinking about night efore
which does not view again here and just
don't have any any any diesel movie yeah
and this is now is a very good version
of the bank oh I put this this on the
board and the thing should be somewhat
okay it's not fantastic of course in
turn 936 so again we just wanted to play
every move instantly g4 like in five
seconds after that you just lost because
I mean what
exactly do you expect me to play like
resigns or or what 94 mm-hmm yeah I
don't know i think him but the tortoise
the engine gives you an equal ish no d6
is actually interesting ever for that
kind of move you have to actually think
of it i cannot take with the pawn that
okay that probably will not end well
perform and FV 8 01 it's just over the
60 strong though will is stronger and
you take quite have to take on d5 I mean
I got a completely confuse the lines
down the 95 the game is over pretty
early on ok guys thanks for watching